well hey there sports friends large and
small near and far foreign wide hi these
multiple players listen I'm trying to be
subtle about it early on we're getting
to the outright jives later on I'm Chris
waters you're watching multiple players
joining me on the couch for some sports
friends it's maxwell McGee hey folks
Mary Kish hello this guy hey Chris at
Shan Shan McInnis oh I'm picking your
nose oh look at your own sake up there
that's why I'm angry yeah that's right
my nose thank God my nose is Mary you're
actually sitting with DD your your oh
that's your weird elf we can't have this
odd Sean and I should switch in that
anyways we're gonna play a video game
it's called sports friends actually on
now your face when I'm just gonna do
this all that is the game that's the
sports ribs game these are four
different video games meant to be played
on the couch next to each other we're
only gonna play three of them because
johann Sebastian joust is like a move
thing need a big space to play it in now
we get a limited space here so where do
you think we should start polarizer see
would you start pro riders cuz we warmed
up on Barry Barry ball & khakhra so yeah
I night start with you I start the run
we don't know anyways game super pull
ride in time uh Maxwell and I are gonna
start on the same team so we got lenders
the worth vendors all right word team
you careful lu you guys are team orange
yellow you need to get like real a real
book oh going oh not today d okay where
are you I'm doing things look at you get
over here oh nevermind it's gonna be
smug the entire on their team oh this is
chaos there's no really
right it just knock again I wish that
our poles were different colors oh yeah
it's so hard to control the pole count
it it's so hard to see you guys need a
work follow these control o Shah eat
pole oh my yeah eat some pole eat some
pole yeah all right now guess what's for
dinner due to the door oh come on team
bend a double burger combo SWAT it down
come in for that stop all the dummies
dog double stops touch a touch incur oh
no no come on LD LD up Oh No
oh shut out oh shut down Oh knows where
Anders win yet yeah Suellen we look so
in love oh no we can't pull no we can't
fall we can't pull right in the middle
oh this is gonna be difficult yeah no no
no there we go no oh yeah from the
heavens no digging it up turn it up why
is he so strong oh that's too strong the
pool is strong with home an admission oh
no poll management yeah that pool
manager oh no Alice Booya oh now come on
take a bit of trash well there's so many
Polti yes get max back I'm back nine
records just kick in na boo we have to
chow a win at some point it's getting
weird maybe they're masters with their
poles I feel like I just don't have
enough pole experience to this what we
have to move on you guys are getting so
I know I can't even enjoy them back
we're getting brutal more in love with
you clock that's of just camping out
together what do you guys want to mix up
the teams or the game I sense mix up the
game all right all right we're gonna go
I feel like we could do this d oh I got
this hello yeah Oh nards
I'll get after first blood here we go oh
oh you like that yeah set a genius
that's good how'd of genius and not an
open I'm over here get it get it get it
get at you that's you tell me all right
and wait wait you do it way don't worry
the way what are you doing nothing you
got nothing you have nothing well I mean
what you are nothing yeah do something
do you think psychological warfare uh oh
you like that whoa didn't get that score
score score score we're like best
friends no okay you got me on good Nick
your juice sucks and you know it Oh
captain you know you almost went to
green he doesn't know where play bad use
it it's hurt oh oh thanks yeah thanks
you guys are the best team shitty
decisions oh oh no you for bringing it
up here oh no oh no now we're Team
shitty version nope oh come on earth our
bed teamwork is starting to harm us oh
no no I'm just gonna dive down I'm just
gonna dodge now go in there go to hide
hide I gotta get back in the box never
leave oh there we go and give up green
purple dominated you okay yeah all right
odds are better larabar a ball somebody
mary and i are blue what the crap these
guys are like a really baby shade of
fuchsia that a baby would be when its
first born we're in stealth mode right
now cuz the background is purple they
get me let it go what I'm a tremor let
it go down oh no no I'm gonna die anyway
let go Chris I made a poor decision now
I slam dunk this ball into oblivion why
are you so big and strong they call me
po po Oh grab a gravity no honey I've it
grab it
oh yeah silly in seconds and score twice
okay score twice I told I just don't die
okay yeah that's what you get for
quitting squares they take them out of
the poll game and all of a sudden they
lose their poles they got nothing I got
nothing going on here I don't know what
happened oh but we lost I think that's
all right now I just sudden death
goodnight hey good match hey let's just
it's let's show a sport like do a
sportsmanship round loser that's it I
need to know about these advanced power
knows that vid by loving I'm just
peeping here yes I don't like this by me
okay oh yeah plus dou dou P mu you're my
boy team blue oh good job how are you
okay score skill and school yeah that
your battle cry yeah oh you like that
thrown the ball at you if you are you
dumb guy yeah big dumb idiot aw crap oh
no I'm out of jumpers Dumbo goose oh
[ __ ] in here did you say this this that
was incredible Maxwell I here it comes
ready for this and my mama mama monster
dunk it Maxwell I died suck it with the
night just keep the ball wave get it
magical you'll get it I got it don't
worry 60ml I'm here standing there I'll
just we're going to sudden DS no one
expects a sudden d oh no [ __ ] Oh Mary
deezer shelf oh oh no what I'm out I'm
out I'm in trouble ha what an idiot what
a what a maroon
actually I'm maroon that's like the dot
that's a good donkey yeah you like that
oh that's the best thing to do are you
not getting it anyway I had no jumps I
have no Joe got to communicate that to
me homie you need to probably aware how
many jumps on it was flexing on Maxwell
real quick and the way that we will
remember this is you got to convey that
to me homie you gotta communicate hold
on where's the where's the Tomlin funny
oh I hit the share button in my search
for the Tong button oh they're okay
they're they did talk they did talk I
was chairman I got a little bit that's a
pretty good that was built of it huh oh
I don't end on losing but you gotta
because you're a loser and we have to
end oh because I did lose that match but
I think overall we all one is ever marry
who is a terrible person what are you
gonna do but a winner ya got that going
for the terrible human being that
happens to be so obviously sports
friends at games that play with people
that you want to get mad at and/or
celebrate your victory over your other
friends at it's really fun those are
three of the four games johann Sebastian
joust another one will try to find a way
to stream that got for you guys sometime
this week his sports prince is out
tomorrow on tuesday i believe so yes
right this we can play on playstation 4
obviously ah but it's also on
playstation 3 and pc I think pc is later
later yeah it's really a fun game of
course we'll have the review comfrey
folks later on and that's going to be it
for multiple players Sean what can folks
look forward to seeing you do tomorrow
morning at 11am in celebration of video
game history month we are playing grand
theft auto san andreas on this the 10th
anniversary of san andreas ten years ago
yeah it's hard to believe them Chuck
it's indeed it looks like yeah so we did
a video for johann Sebastian joust way
back in the day by that ammonia a year I
don't know what's a good way to find
that use it i just googled johan
fashion jiao's gamespot and the video is
just called johann Sebastian joust video
preview so pretty straight for see if
you can find when I accidentally punched
on mcshay ratio accident thank you
thanks for watching multiple players
everybody every monday at two p.m. we
love to see you here thanks again for
watching we'll see you tomorrow